a young trained stewardess starts her
first day at work in a normal looking
train where several hundred passengers
are present some are traveling for work
while others are just trying to spend
their holidays with their loved ones but
after just 10 minutes when the train
reaches a particular station Everything
Changes the carriages become old and
Rusty people start going crazy and a
bloodbath takes place the stewardess who
is expecting a great first day at work
is traumatized because of what she sees
following this we are taken back to the
year 1988 little Omi son is excited as
it's her birthday today she's patiently
waiting for her dad to arrive with her
special present Nissan's dad works on a
train as a conductor while her
grandmother lies in front of the
television Misan plays with her toy
train however she quickly becomes bored
and tries to get some attention from her
grandmother when the old woman doesn't
respond Misan shakes her by the shoulder
but the woman's lifeless body falls
heavily onto the toy train destroying it
from the television we learn the
shocking news that there's been a
horrible accident in the train bringing
me son's dad back home is now a mass of
burning crushed metal it's then revealed
that misan's grandmother had a heart
attack after learning about her son's
death following this we are shown the
actual scene of the disaster there are
two small children a boy and a girl with
an injured arm the children stare in
horror at the body of their mother who
has been killed trying to protect them
from the crash fast forward 15 years
Misan is now a stewardess who has just
started her job on a train some people
blame her dad who was the conductor on
the crashed train however Misan ignores
everyone and carries out her work later
we learned that the train is departing
from Seoul station to yosu at 11 50 PM
there are many passengers boarding it
but the main ones are a couple heju and
her boyfriend who are going for a
honeymoon a group of four teenagers who
are paranormal activity investigators
and two other schoolgirls who have just
bunked their classes the train then
departs at the said time a while later a
couple arrives at the station and the
wife is worried that they missed the
train but surprisingly at 12 o'clock AM
a second train arrives and the couple
boards it back on the first train the
captain Mr Park makes an announcement he
mentions that this is the last time the
train is going to yosu station after
this both he and the train will retire
moreover it is revealed that some parts
of the train have the same coaches that
were used in the crashed train 15 years
ago because of this people often
theorize that this train is haunted
shortly after the schoolgirls from
before purposely Collide With Me son's
food trolley and steal some chocolates
Misan notices this but she doesn't say a
word instead she goes to a corner and
starts munching on one of the snacks
herself she is interrupted by the
Train's conductor Jin Q who invites her
to a farewell party for Mr Park later
the pair along with the staff head
celebrate the farewell party with the
captain and congratulate him on his
retirement following the party Mr Park
goes back to the control room where he
suddenly sees a girl standing on the
train track terrified he quickly pulls
the brake handle causing all the
passengers to lose their balance for a
while but he goes to check on the track
he doesn't see anybody there next the
Paranormal Activity team interviews one
of the train passengers about his
experience on the train the man starts
off by saying that today is the same
date on which the horrific accident took
place 15 years ago the passenger then
reveals that ever since the incident he
travels every year on the train on its
accident anniversary because he lost his
parents on the fateful day he also tells
the investigation team that three years
ago he had seen a man with a briefcase
on the train but he quickly vanished
Into Thin Air the passenger then takes
the team to the place where the man was
seated learning this Sue hee one of the
girls from the team feels a weird Aura
around the seat so he is a psychic who
can see spirits Elsewhere on the train
Misan approaches a boy named hu Wang who
is traveling alone and sketching some
pictures in his drawing book The Boy
tells the stewardess that his mother is
waiting for him at the next stop when
Misan looks at the drawing book she
finds that Huang has drawn some
passengers that were not on the train
but before she can take a closer look at
it the boy snatches it away attempts to
destroy it forcing Misan to leave soon
after she starts seeing weird things
around the Train the vehicle starts
transforming into an old and dark train
with spiders crawling all over the place
she also starts getting glimpses of the
spirits of those who died in the crash
15 years prior but suddenly everything
goes back to normal after that me sun
sees an unknown stewardess and follows
her to the coach next door in the
process she trips her leg but when she
gets up Misan finds herself on the same
old train and now the passengers have
also changed when she looks back she
sees a scary figure with long hair that
immediately attacks her Misan screams in
horror and Corners in a passenger seat
but the surroundings quickly go back to
being normal and now the figure is
changed into a black wig Sue hee who
witnesses everything picks up the wig
and asks the passengers if it belongs to
them for a while no one says a word but
just then one of the Arrogant
schoolgirls lies that it's hers and
takes the wig with her later Misan is
called upon by her staff supervisor who
scolds her for scaring the passengers
but before matters can escalate the
Train's conductor Jin Q arrives and
convinces the supervisor to go easy on
Misan as it's her first day at work
after this the frightened stewardess
goes to take some rest in the next scene
we are taken to the second train the
couple who boarded the train at 12 a.m
are still there the wife jumie is pretty
scared since there isn't anyone on the
train except for them but when jonghyun
looks around he sees Professor Kim who
used to teach him at the University he
then approaches the professor who is
carrying a briefcase with him the movie
then Cuts back to the first train the
girl who lied about the wig goes to the
bathroom and tries it on but suddenly
she feels like someone is grabbing her
neck when the girl tries to look around
the wig wraps around her neck and chokes
her to death whoa that got hairy next
the train stops at a station and from a
window Misan notices the boy who Wang
unboarding the train fearing that he
might get lost she quickly follows him
outside but he's already gone Misan then
decides to return to the train but
suddenly she her father sitting in one
of the passenger seats and becomes
horrified fortunately Jin Q reminds her
that the train is leaving prompting
Nissan to snap back to reality and
hurriedly enter the train meanwhile a
woman enters the bathroom to have a
smoke she appears to be in a bad mood as
her boyfriend got off the train at a
recent station leaving her alone just
then lights start flickering and his
Spirit suddenly appears in front of her
and attacks her smoking kills the movie
then takes us to the second train where
Professor Kim is talking with a fellow
passenger the passenger is none other
than me son's dad who is showing a music
box that he is planning to give to his
daughter meanwhile the professor
explains that he is traveling to yosu to
submit his dissertation which is inside
his briefcase at this moment we realize
that the couple Zhang Hyun and jumi
boarded a ghost train that crashed 15
years ago moreover the professor and
misan's dad are spirits who haven't
realized that they are actually dead
back on the first train Jin q and Misan
find the body of the woman who had gone
to the bathroom to smoke the corpse
looks like the woman was terrified to
death Jin Q hurriedly tries to inform
the central office while Misan retrieves
the dead woman's phone she finds several
unread messages from the woman's
boyfriend suggesting she get off the
train immediately apparently he had seen
some spirits on the train after he had
gotten off taken aback Misan leaves the
corpse and walks out suddenly the train
starts transforming into an old one once
again Misan sees the same unknown
stewardess who tells her that she made a
mistake working on that train the
stewardess then tells a confused and
anxious me son that they are all going
to die distressed me son starts
screaming at the stewardess but in
reality it turns out that she is
screaming at her lady supervisor after
that Misan Falls unconscious on the
floor while unconscious she sees a
vision where it is revealed that the
unknown stewardess worked on the train
that crashed 15 years ago her name was
Jung Jin Sook and while on duty she had
mistakenly kicked a bottle of poison
destroying it completely but before we
get to know more Misan regains her
Consciousness later she talks about her
visions and dreams with Jin q but the
latter is confused and doesn't
understand any of it Misan then decides
to ask for help from suhee the psychic
as the two talk so he reveals that she
too has been feeling a strange Aura ever
since the train stopped at the last
station the pair then go to the restroom
where the dead woman's body lies so he
tries to go near the corpse but she
starts feeling uncomfortable as if
something is stopping her elsewhere we
see heiju and her boyfriend they are the
same couple that we saw at the start of
the movie who are on their way to their
honeymoon from their conversation we
learned that hiju is the same girl among
the two children that survived the
accident 15 years ago meanwhile Sue he
learns from a stack of newspapers that
who Wang the boy who me son tried to
find after he got off the train alone
had also died 15 years ago we realized
that most of the passengers that Misan
is tending to are spirits from the
horrific accident on the other side of
the train one of suhi's friends is
killed by the stewardess jinsuk's Spirit
a while later when Misan goes to check
on suhi she finds that the latter has
now fallen unconscious on the floor
surprisingly someone has stabbed her
before Sue he breathes her last she
feebly reveals that most of the
passengers on the train are possessed by
Spirits from the past among them are
hiju and her boyfriend who have been
possessed by the spirits of the two
children who were in the crash with
their parents 15 years ago and they are
intent on crashing the train moreover
the most confusing part is that the
spirits themselves do not know that they
are dead so they are traveling as
passengers on the train learning this
Misan immediately takes off to confront
the couple but before she can explain to
them that they have been possessed he
sues boyfriend stabs her from behind as
a result misu Falls unconscious again on
the floor meanwhile Jin Q cannot get the
train to stop by a station as it was
supposed to he gets confused and the
passengers also start fretting elsewhere
as Misan regains Consciousness she sees
her father next to her the spirit calms
her down and reveals that their train
will collide with a second train and
after the Collision all the spirits will
know that they are already dead and the
weird weird phenomenon will finally stop
occurring just then Jin Q approaches her
and prepares to take her back to safety
suddenly the lights go out and the coach
which they are in turns old again they
see blood oozing out of the floor and
from there the scary Jin souk crawls out
however when she attempts to possess me
son Jin Q shows up and tells her that he
will always be with her here it is
revealed that Jin q and Jin Suk used to
see each other before the stewardess
died in the accident the spirit then
leaves me son and slowly curls up and
her former boyfriend's arms meanwhile as
the lights go out in some coaches glass
starts falling on the passengers and the
spirits finally start to realize that
they are in somebody else's body next
Misan goes to the control room where she
finds hiju and her boyfriend the couple
has killed the captain and changed the
course of their track in such a way that
the train will eventually crash with
another one and kill everyone on board
Misan tries to convince hiju that they
have been possessed and because of this
the latter starts getting a vision hiju
sees the 15 years back she along with
her family were traveling on the train
they were supposedly going to a beach to
have fun but in reality the father was
planning to kill them all with the help
of poison however his plans were foiled
when the stewardess jinsuk accidentally
kicked and destroyed the bottle enraged
the father dragged the stewardess into
the control room killed her and the
captain and put the Train on a collision
course with another train this is what
caused the terrible wreck over a decade
ago back in the present heju's boyfriend
bashes me son's head several times
against the window causing her to
collapse but contrary to him hiju
regresses into the little girl from 15
years ago in the next scene the spirit
of misan's Father enters the control
room and Pilots the train out of Harm's
Way while hiju's boyfriend also reverts
to his original Self and starts
comforting his sister shortly after as
the two trains the one which is natural
and the other which is haunted begin to
part things start going back to normal
on the original train for instance the
ghosts start disassembling the old
coaches transform back to being normal
again and the terrified passengers start
coming out of hiding in the control room
Nissan is comforted by her father saying
that soon they will see each other in
heaven with this she dies from her head
injuries at the same time the train
finally stops it's daytime and the
disoriented passengers get off the final
scene of the movie shows that it is
night again and the train for yosu
arrives at Soul station for its last run
we see me sun on the platform and she is
again a stewardess on this train on its
unnatural Journey subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching